looky there such a small right here no
no he's a thick hair okay dan has been
studying himself this video is about a
video that I saw of it where you can
actually dry can idiot you can drop a
swimming hair on to someone's head just
with the force of the war that's it it
so you know you get around the way
married or just scraping it down let's
see if it works okay I'm sorry this
person got it right yeah
ah
Oh God's me okay yeah it might be easy
to apply however not easy to apply
correctly I could exactly start swimming
out with
like it's like it's the quickest time I
don't ever put a half-ton before I think
do they go faster on the front of your
face or just in God we got to try that
yeah all right do it again but lie on
your back
oh yes sweet dangling over this is not
good look at this Freddie Oh Oh God this
way bit this way over there you gave my
chin this number at me in the face you
start to suffocate pull it off
immediately all right ready yeah I went
down with those there you go that's
might there just go oh god this is all
for outside this isn't gonna work
yeah let's cool it down that one the
other one was this successful test ah
you
so in this video we learned that gravity
is excellent at putting on swimming caps
over the top of the head not the front
um yeah don't put a hat on your face
with gravity put on your head
vision slightly it's not great success
about chlorine and hat in my eye
well I hope you enjoyed that video be
sure to follow us on Twitter ate success
and subscribe see you in the next one
don't go for a dip oh yeah sure you man
this video is brought to you by
audible.com if you want to sign up for a
free audiobook use the link audible.com
for slash slo-mo is over 150,000 books I
recommend one more thing
bye BJ Novak is very funny it's very
short it was in the office nice about it